she returns to live performances welcome
to show singer Marlene Ricci it is so
good to have you here with us thank you
and it's so good to have you back in the
Limelight you've been doing other things
and this is kind of a step back into
that Spotlight it is in October yep
October 6th at the Italian American Club
and um it's a dinner and show so it's a
pretty good value kind of like the old
days remember right you you have seen
the evolution of Las Vegas because it
was the late 70s when you were
discovered and by Frank Sinatra and
really got your career going what is
what are some of the huge differences
you see between then and now oh boy well
back then they did have dinner shows and
you could go in and people would dress
up and it was like a big event and then
you got to see the greatest
entertainment here you know in Las Vegas
and then now it's mostly uh Production
shows yeah so that to me is the biggest
difference you don't get to see well a
few people come in still but it's it's
more of a rarity you're right and it's a
little more corporate on that side of
the equation yes what can people expect
at your show well I'm going to do a
variety of Music uh some from the 70s
and 80s and I like the nostalgic stuff
I'm going to do some 40s things that I
did learn from Frank Sinatra he did a
saloon segment in his show and it was
always a dramatic portion and he he was
acting in it but I'm gonna do that then
do some contemporary things too as some
Adele have to do right right so it'll be
a nice variety of stuff for all ages but
uh I probably have the Sinatra crowd or
the people that were fans of his I think
would I'd hope to come in and I think
you could do a wholesale just telling
stories about what you experienced
because you opened for Frank Sinatra for
a while yep for almost three years yeah
that probably you could fill in a couple
hours just talking about that things
that happened backstage and his
personality he was just so great to
watch and he was really he would warm up
before every show he really was a you
know professional did you see him as a
mentor in that respect I did yeah what's
what was your biggest takeaway well I
always be on time you know a lot of and
then to just give it be yourself he said
you know you don't have to try to be
anybody else that was like really great
Marley advice I wish I could talk to you
forever I really appreciate you being
here and let's tell people again Marlene
Ricci performing October 6th at the
Italian American Club that's going to be
a great show you can learn more about it
at that website right there Rocky